hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Skyrim okay we came upon a
chest fine
yes please yes please yes please I can't
come that item okay I seem to be
equipping it whatever
why did it go automatically go to the
Dwarven bow for my sword yeah okay what
did you say Esbern huh
oh you saying I'm about some big face
lady go talk to the face that would make
sense your blood my blood this is where
you cut me open you know the ancient
blades revered we ever do uh-huh
no my blood do I need to do Lydia take
my blood
Lydia you got the dagger just cut me
open from navel the sternum come on
Lydia God Lou you don't do anything it's
probably right try using your blood on
the carb ceiling floor okay after the
so-called Battle of pelo pass the Kaviri
with you to his service this was the
foundation stone
why is Lydia's just standing there Susan
why Lydia okay good
how do i oh shut up
a-hole okay good for us good for me
Lydia was squeamish to do it
bye-bye big face
okay sure it will be phenomenal and
amazing huh huh huh what Lydia what I
get whoo that's birdie
okay so chairs and tables nice
whoa-oh-oh this is the wall from the
trailer the this is the trailer wall see
there's the thing and there's the guy
doing the thing and there's the
Dragonborn and the fire was like you
know and it dawns in fire but there is
one day fear in their tongue he is
Dovahkiin
Dragonborn women fus-ro-dah didn't know
all that awesome orchestral piece where
did they go
the hell's going on hurry up
you can see how they are cavalry
craftsmen we're beginning every era
flowing Nordic III don't care we're here
for all doings wall right as burn yes
we'll have more time to look around
later yeah let's see what's up ahead
this is actually the voice sector that
did that trailer so I'm wondering if
like he's gonna say some things from it
I have no idea
probably not well well now
things are getting more interesting
come on old man hurry up uh-huh
Baldwin's walls so uh huh I've never
seen a fine example of early second
there are Kabira sculpture oh god you're
boring me to tears man we have a wall
come on now come on
look here is Aldrin a rags panel goes
back to the beginning of child of Gaghan
Aldrin and the Dragons rule Thomas
Chiron sounds good just skywrite here
the humans rebelled against that back
okay defeat is the centerpiece ah
you see here is falling from the sky the
North x masters of the voice are arrayed
okay
patience the UH Kaviri were not a
straightforward people everything is
couched mystic symbol interesting coming
from the mouth of the Lord heroes this
is the Kaviri symbol for shout ah
there's no way to know what just meant a
big one
you mean they used a shout to defeat all
the words so you st. have to shout at
this wall no you're saying oh yes okay
this is where they recorded all that you
so we're looking for a shout uh-huh damn
it never heard of such a thing a shout
that can knock a dragon oh hi goddammit
lady I swear why do they keep doing this
to me the gray beers mine they're
probably right I was hoping to avoid
having to involve them in this why seems
we have no choice but you got against
the gray beards they're just old men up
on a mountain right
whoop session about yet again sergeant
what no the third man audism' done the
prophecy which I may why am I so slow
what why is it suddenly shifted where I
have to press shift to run what what the
hell is going on here see I'm walking oh
I hit caps locks oh okay all right come
on Lydia
hey we got places to go apparently gotta
go talk to the Greybeards Qarth spire I
hope my a horse he'll stay with me
I don't wanna lose horsey oh I got a
good run all the way out of the temple
again bullcrap
ah oh [ __ ] that was bad that was that
was that was that was dumb
that was dumb okay Lydia take two Lydia
why didn't you warn me about that
why didn't you like grab my collar or
something Lydia
leave me and my death in them all right
anyway that never happened
you didn't see anything no one saw
anything the video feed cut out things
happened we got to go get to the
Greybeards ask what shout killed the
darkens and then well I don't know
something to that yeah it's me weird
that the dragons cuz the shouts are like
just words said the Dragons say why
would the Dragons have a word that would
kill dragons and what kind of word would
that be I don't even know I don't even
understand half of what the dragon stuff
is horsey there's a dragon where's my
horsey there he is
always down there murdering some people
come here weepy mmm I know you can't run
you can't run hello where's my horsey
horsey horsey where do you go
who's he with Chuck there oh my or
cement oh you want some [ __ ]
I mean douche bit now you [ __ ]
all right oh man my horse you went
running that way I don't know why I
spent a thousand gold on that horse I
want to get to stick with me rather and
I'm hoping that one time on it then when
I fast travel to the Greybeards it'd
just be like bonk bonk bonk there maybe
I should take care of that dragon and
maybe while I'm taking the care of the
dragon that force will come back I don't
know
wishful thinking I suppose come here
dargon come here dargon Berrigan Gargan
I got a present for you long and slender
and as a sharp point on it where you
throwing fireballs at me there's a
friggin Dargan right there
fine you want some yecchh
Agra Oh wonder the Dragons took to fight
with you
now you can don't do much damage but
you're top part you can heal not fair
whoa dragon oh now I got both of them
fighting me regeneration and then wall
there we go
get some Oh use that power
apparently Wow none of them [ __ ] hey I
heard like a guy is just attacking
are you doing there's a dragon stop
attacking me what's the acronym
elderness
hi Raven feathers when it's a hag Raven
why was it there come on kill it kill it
level up level up perfect timing more
health I don't see any reason to get
anything besides health well maybe I'll
get some stamina later on but for now oh
man why is my armor not raising up at
all I swear I've been getting hitting
good getting the head plenty but just
nothing increases oh you know I don't
even know I increase this notebook and
not I can't do anything because my
skills just don't increase I swear I
have the warrior I have the warrior
bless anything going on but just nothing
happening
whatever it's all good good hold on you
gonna die today dragon there's something
off what Smith it's a dead dragon yeah
give me your [ __ ] well okay pony my pony
find me no damn it where's Lydia my fast
travel while I'm in combat do a little
light there
oh I can't faster have all of those
enemies give me your soul whoa I get
murdered out here
prepare to die Eminem is [ __ ] something
is destroying me Oh what are you doing
looter really a looter okay was that all
of them Oh Lydia
there you are really after I kill
everything that's when you show up Lydia
I swear I swear Lydia I don't know why I
put up with you I mean you're pretty as
a peach but come on it's at one point
it's just not worth it right yeah great
beers about some dragon shout that will
kill the Dargan does that make sense
where are you dude are you sleeping
again really really old man just you saw
you did you not sleep you know training
process II where did you learn of that
who have you been all doings wall
weights aha gates they have always
sought to turn the dragon but have you
learned nothing from us no would you
simply be a tool in the hands of the
blade yes used for their own purpose I
own purposes no no of course not forgive
me Oh Oh have been in temperatures but
heed my warning
the blades may say they serve the
Dragonborn but they do not know they do
not have I have no I cannot teach it to
you because I do not know well what good
are you old dragon rent but it's words
of power are unknown - you're a bit of a
dick aren't you reckless loss dragon
rent holds no place within the way of
the voice okay but it can killed Argon's
but not dragon rent the knowledge of
that shop was lost in the time before
history began that was a long time ago I
think that was before the wings of its
annual other time for it I am not the
one Land Before Time series anyway you
ever watch The Land Before Time live one
the unimaginable cruelty their whole
lives are consumed with hatred for
dragons and they poured all their anger
and hatred into this shot sounds good to
me when you learn a shout you take it
into your very be aa sense you become a
shout okay in order to learn and use
this shout you will be taking this even
into yourself I'm okay with that only
parts of necks the master of our order
can answer that question if he so
chooses okay
he is our leader he lives in seclusion
on the very peak of the mountain this
beautiful only rarely and never to
outsiders mm-hmm being allowed to see
him visit only those whose voice is
strong can find the - the strong gear
teach you a shout to open the way to
Paarthurnax good you better do SH don't
think I've forgotten how useless you are
well I guess I shouldn't be so mean he's
gonna teach me a shout for free come on
enough with the walking old man let's
get some run get some spring in your
step where are we going even we're going
outside oh oh even opening a damn door
you just you just click it you just hit
the button and then you're done hit your
button old man Oh screw this screw you
guys
God me I swear Lydia come here all right
oh my god they're the slowest I've ever
seen this is just unbelievable
boy boy little beer oh is this the way
up the mountain
it's the impassable whoa no Lydia you
just saw me walking and get her why
would you get hurt
Lydia get out of there Lydia are you are
you okay are you right in the head you
seem a little special sometimes I mean
really Lydia
whose ghost Afton's but it's okay
whatever okay we didn't get out of the
man's way
okay I'm looking at it
clear skies
I wonder if that's like the only purpose
for a shot is just to clear away my
understanding this is your final gift
from us dragon why you know all the
words why can't you just give me all of
them it seems like it would make my job
a lot easier
clear skies throw away the mist on the
path to pass an axe is perilous uh-huh
not to be embarked upon lightly don't
care keep moving
stay focused on your goal uh-huh and you
will reach the summit okay
okay off I go let me put that into my
favorites menu come real why can't I use
that one all right so we got this guy
okay whoosh being careful whoop walk not
all look now call
all right
is that the only one I bet they're
probably oh hello go how did you get up
oh I need it
wha okay whatever gets cloudy and for
you wow I could fall off that nun very
easily come on Lydia are you still there
Lydia Lydia don't get distracted by the
goat Lydia whoa what the hell is that
oh no I fought back when I first played
yeah this is something coming straight
at me out of the out of the fog I didn't
know what the hell it was and fog
doesn't really seem all that ha ha yeah
help me out here Lydia please kill it
yes you don't it's not that you have to
I'm telling you to kill it
why can't Lydia just be bloodthirsty and
whatever uh hey another goat you're
ready to die goat he's ready to die
give me your goat meat nothing nothing
the goat is empty and it had nothing
good is that what Owen otherone get out
of here
don't even try you're not tough enough
Lydia I swear Lydia did you really just
yeah that was not my fault he walked
right into it what was I supposed to do
maybe I swear I swear Oh Oh is it Fatah
or not off look what oh I almost there
one is there why is this guy living up
here anyway I mean what's the point
just to be some sort of monk-like
seclusion stamina maybe I should have
invested more stamina just to be able to
run more another goat goat goat goat
let's go fly ba ba ba ba Lydia don't
make me do you don't make me I will
Lydia Lydia you don't need to fight the
goat the goats dead goats gone man that
is awesome
by the way I I don't appreciate much but
I mean I do appreciate but I don't
appreciate enough how awesome this is
everything down there is just part of
the world that I could walk in I could
like if I could had like a flying
ability I could like jump off this and
go straight down there it's amazing
anyway off the mountain Cobb on Lydia oh
I'm on a cool-down I shouldn't have
blown that goat off the mountain shut up
come on come on oh come on haha look
photos
all right throat of the world ooh
wall thingy who do I get a word oh [ __ ]
hello goodbye Oh greetings oh sorry are
you what brings you to my strudel mom
sorry buddy my Mountain
hi I'm the track or I didn't just try to
kill you
yeah I think you know who I am
Vasa you speak true dovakiin forgive me
yeah
it has been long since I held Timbuk
with a stranger him feh I gave in to the
temptation to prolong our speech even
our by log there are many hungers it is
better to deny than to feel I suppose so
Trek Nanaki the discipline against the
lesser aids in Kutner denial of the
greater okay tell me why do you come
here for long
why do you intrude on my meditation um
teach me how to kill dragons
gem patience
there are formalities which must be
observed at the first meeting of two of
the dough okay and what is my long
tradition oh we're gonna talk to each
other okay I'll get ready Peabody first
ready to watch
I'm ready buddy sorry I slashed your
face and got blood all over you why do
you involve okay
well watch this wait what I was gonna
shower
final as the dope
okay so I need to speak fire or what oh
yeah give me that knowledge or your soul
okay yeah I was wondering when I was
gonna get to learn to breathe fire let
me show you how the are gonna injure
each other huh sorry sorry Bucky that
was the wrong one actually it'd be
quicker though there we go I didn't even
faze her yes I had the pleasure of
speech with one of my own it would be
weird if this guy was like a human nope
at the top of the mount he's like um red
fire all over me yeah no easy task for a
jaw I'm not more even for one of dov'è
source dragon blood yeah what would you
ask of me teach me how to kill people
like you I have expected you Frodo you
would not come all this way fourteen
[ __ ] [ __ ] with an old no ha no you
seek your weapon against our doing
yep that sounds about right let's see
yes they are very protective of me
Balam Fatah Milan father but I do not
know the thumb you see closest it cannot
be known to me maha interested your kind
jaw mortals created it as a weapon
against the dole the dragon so it's like
saying [ __ ] you do the dragons as loud
as little more and then they just can
fell out of the sky in its concerts the
grey bear said it was like now Malcolm
ation of hate and anger towards the
dragon so they were just looking up at
this guy like so much that sounds about
right
did him all in good time first a
question for you why do you want to
learn this to kill Morde Argon's I laugh
I like this world
I don't want it then that's good a
reason as in here there are many who
feel as you do although not all uh-huh
some would say that all things must end
so that the next can come to pop you
have the world answered nothing else can
come out of hurts this world is simply
the egg of the next culpa leave okay you
lost me buddy
would you stop the next world from being
born yes
screw that world our world's best go
world number one world a world a one
has our fair unsere about that bro FUS
maybe you only balance the forces that
work to quicken the end of this world
possibly old man even we who ride the
currents of time cannot see past times
and will City lost rewarding what you
call me those who try to hasten the end
may delay it those who work to delay the
end may bring it closer ok but you have
indulged my weakness for speech long
enough ok closest now I will answer your
question alright then
bring it on do you know why I live here
at the peak of the more Navon what you
named throat of the world because you're
an old recluse facts is like mountains
right and true but few now remember that
was the very spot I got it I got a hawk
through this mmm
then nope it was the cloud the Elder
Scroll they used it - how - it's ok the
Kelly it's what that but series of names
is merely a small part ok not so Alduin
is somewhere in lost in time if you
brought that
look that ah so I have to go get the
oldest goal to go through time to go
find though all the wind create no I got
to go back in time to find the people
that create it and learn it from them
haha it's so messed up but I mean wow
you are likely better it trust your
instincts okay I gotta see but no
dovakiin ah others meditate on looking
okay okay I got a run all the time buddy
wheeler it's not my time Paarthurnax
teen what would hold you to deeper
understand my hear me brother let's just
go with disease called think of the way
for AHA that is force okay let its
meaning feel you're soon our market you
will alright still I have to go harder
go greet you know I have to go thank you
oh my god
alright that's all the time that I have
right now whoa Inez all wrong anyway
that's all the time I have for now thank
you guys so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next part
bye bye